people have a hard time talking about
money because money is the root of all
of our problems
my relationship with the money is I
don't understand money my name is Quinn
I'm 22 years old and I live in San
Francisco I'm a software engineering
intern at a small startup do you mind
telling me how your day started I woke
up and then went in my car to get
something and found out that had been
towed and how much did that cost
I got a 90 something dollar discount
because it was the first time I closed
the code it still came out to almost
$600 so we're starting today yeah
I'm paid $2,000 a week so for a 40-hour
week that's $50 now
so computer science is something I had
just dabbled in as a requirement for my
math degree and then I just decided to
do it
and he's with me as well I'm Dolly
Avenue I am 23 years old and I live in
Los Angeles California
I make a living using my camera to take
pictures so the great thing about
freelancing is you never really know how
much you're gonna make how much do you
think you ran about four or five K so I
like C++ but I don't get to work and C++
a lot what kind of programming do you
want to go into oh gosh
good luck
[Applause]
hi you look cute
oh my gosh
getting into the office I probably spend
about 30 minutes to an hour just
figuring out what I was doing last time
I was working I like where I work a lot
right now
do I love coding no it's too much of how
the sausage is made thank you for the
tea so today we were shooting with
Brooke who wanted to make a calendar for
her boyfriend bubbles
it's gotta be funny fit 530 East 8th
Street I'm assuming this way friends
sweet Thanks awesome intimate space
you know straight on more angled you me
sitting and stuff anyways yeah be cool
yeah just let me know if anything else
but let's get it my favorite thing in
the photograph hands down is people I
absolutely love the energy and
understanding somebody I think that's
what what makes me keep creating takes
so much for someone to be completely
confident and vulnerable so allowing me
into their space and capturing their
soul in a sense I think that's rewarding
you look great and if you smile smile
that way dude see what go smile anybody
else upgrade to X 26 oh my Can I grab a
spinach and goat cheese quiche and a
matcha latte
I think that people problems are more
interesting than technical problems so
my favorite part of my day as a software
developer is when I got to solve the
problem with someone else so I guess I
could be happier if I was just teaching
high school I think it's important that
you aim for things you're passionate
about but that need not be grounded in
your career like I would not want my
parents to feel insecure about my future
after my third semester of college my
dad was diagnosed with multiple myeloma
which is a type of bone marrow cancer
and I'm his only child so if I want me
to take care of him luckily he came out
the other side there is no way I could
value two years in the middle of my life
over two years potentially at the end of
his my decision to take care of him was
very like logical because that's the
type of person I am that's the way I
solve problems
[Laughter]
[Music]
like we're the Kardashians and we're
just having somebody oh man you can hear
me
[Music]
these are gonna look so good I had a
tough life because my parents were
incompatible emotional abuse physical
abuse on top of that they didn't have an
education they're trying to find a job
trying to find a place to live and
having children to take care of our
circumstances put us in situations that
weren't ideal that's how we grew up and
from there we just kind of learned how
to survive I think like with money if
you make the effort to change your
mentality in your lifestyle that goes
even with your career and if you're
open-minded to change like you can
pursue anything that you put your mind
to that's where I'm trying to do with
art look back at me
perfect gotta Photoshop your friend out
[Music]
do you believe that money to find
yourself or or others
yes
money is part of what turns you into who
you are
in almost every person that I've ever
met like I wish it were different I
don't think money defines you I think
your character defines you I think how
you treat people defines you and also
how you treat yourself defines you it's
kind of ingrained in us right money is
quite literally how much you are worth
no matter how you try to spin it like
there is a number and I'm sure to some
degree we all say that it doesn't like
money can't buy happiness all right but
a lack of money can lose you some
happiness are you happy
I think I'm happy I wake up and look
forward to my day could I be happier yes
absolutely
like it's not in my nature to pin a
point what would make me happier I think
everybody wants to strive for more I
think I'm happy in terms of I'm making
art and I'm getting paid for it I didn't
really have anything and I was happy so
because of that at the end of a day I
don't really feel like hmm what's the
question
[Music]
so what's your day looking like you
could do the math on your head
$400 a day every day how much should I
spend 48 bucks plus the 600 from this
morning puts us at 650 dollars fish
how do you feel about that day you know
besides the car it was pretty good
[Music]
no freedom caged bird
how much money did you make today unless
you well for the most part the three
hours I made four hundred and she paid
for the studio with just 80 dollars
we're still deciding moving forward with
the image cost
[Music]
it's really good
how do I know the darkness can keep you
in sometimes the doubt of the blurred
lines can keep the sunlight from
creeping in from crepe
[Music]